Así es se detectó con un sistema Ultra
secreto de detección de movimientos
acústicos bajo el agua de la Marina y
inmediatamente pues se informó de estos
de estos sonidos de esta implosión que
se había escuchado a los comandantes al
frente de las labores de búsqueda pero
como no estaba claro De dónde procedía
esta este sonido pues se decidió seguir
buscando a esos cinco tripulantes y a
ese sumergible pues como como con la
esperanza de que todavía estuvieran
vivos al parecer es una implosión que se
escuchó horas después compañeros de que
se sumergible bajara al fondo Marino de
que hiciera Esa primera inmersión el
domingo por la mañana
ahora que se estima que el sumergible
si ahora lo importante ha dicho la
guardia urbana es recoger la guardia
costera recoger la máxima información de
hecho ya han dicho que ese robot
sumergible que era conducido de manera
remota permanecerá en la escena donde se
han encontrado estas cinco piezas del
sumergible titán para recabar toda la
información que sea posible y analizarla
porque ahora lo más importante también
es saber qué ha ocurrido exactamente la
parte de la siguiente parte que sigue es
precisamente las labores de rescate de
esas piezas que faltan todavía que no va
a ser nada fácil compañeros porque no
olvidemos que se sumergible pesa
alrededor de 10 toneladas y va a ser muy
difícil conseguir esas piezas que faltan
también porque se encuentran a una gran
profundidad donde no pueden bajar los
buzos humanos hay que trabajar todavía
con esos artefactos submarinos que se
conducen de manera remota y para que os
hagáis también una idea de la dificultad
que entraña esta misma mañana antes de
que se diera a conocer esta información
este hallazgo la Marina Estaba tratando
de llevar hasta la costa de Terranova un
artefacto de gran peso que podría
recuperar embarcaciones a más de 6.000
metros de profundidad